when I was in high school my parents
didn't want me to get my elves or my
appease early because I think they were
they were anxious that I would know get
the crash and kill Wes or something like
that so therefore for a long time if I
want to get from A to B all I could do
was cycle okay so I had my bike and that
would get me I was like a reasonable
sort of radius that I could ride around
and as a bonus I was a lot of feedback
there so that was fine but then when I
got into UT I got my elves got my Peas
started driving okay but here's the
funny thing when you learn to drive has
anyone actually started lessons at all
okay fantastic thank you here's that
when you start to learn to drive at the
beginning it's quite overwhelming
because you're like things that should
seem simple like turning or breaking you
suddenly realize what my goodness like
how do I control this thing and not make
everyone feel sick because you did you
win so suddenly know that so driving is
a whole set of skills right but
eventually fingers crossed you will come
to the point where I am where I'm very
comfortable driving I don't even need to
think well I'm driving even though I
assured but here's the thing which I'm
getting across to you I've learnt many
things about driving I'd say I'm a
decent driver however
not even gonna dignify that with a
response
I am know how to drive but at the same
time there are so many things I do not
know about this one-ton object that I am
pushing around the roads okay I can
confidently say to you that I know
pretty much nothing about how an engine
works apart from the fact that number
one there is an engine number two
it requires petrol cause I have to pay
for that and number three like it has
something to do with like little
explosions that happen work because this
is called a combustion Estrin engine
which is explosions that's all I know
okay if something even tiny is going
wrong with this do not ask me I'm gonna
get on the phone to the NRA as soon as
possible okay now let me ask you this
and it's a question for each of one of
you individually right because
everyone's like some people really
interested in this right is a car any
less impressive because you can still
drive it and have a lot of fun with it
without knowing anything about how its
engine works right in fact I would argue
that is exactly how it's being designed
it's been designed specifically so that
you can operate it and enjoy it and be
good at it without having to worry about
the nitty-gritty details right you just
have to worry about your steering wheel
you get all that kind of thing and all
of this is hidden from you okay now why
am I talking about this okay do you
remember yesterday actually the day
before we talked about this guy do you
member that and in fact you've already
used it today okay now what I did was I
showed you this sign rule but I did you
more I did more for you than show you
the same rule I actually showed you the
engine of the same rule we just didn't
come up with it we didn't just say this
is true and you can operate it you can
use it without knowing why I actually
showed you where it came from and what
makes it work okay
now I could do the same for the cosine
rule okay in fact pretty much everything
you guys learn if you want I can show
you the engine today though I actually
want to focus on just driving this thing
if you want I will give you all the
actual working to demonstrate the proof
it's in your textbook so you could read
it yourself if you so choose but today I
just want to put you behind the steering
wheel okay so I'm not gonna prove it for
you
I'm not gonna derive it is the way we
would say it I'm just gonna show it to
you and then we're gonna get behind the
wheel okay I do have a metaphor person
okay pin it there Eddie okay next your
right angle triangle if you label your
sides a B and C then by Pythagoras
theorem you can say what okay I'm just
gonna write it from right to left it
reversed for how you said it's the same
property right same theory so this
relates the hypotenuse with the two
shorter sides okay but we know it only
works in right-angled triangles so what
happens when you don't have a
right-angled triangle well we already
know this guy we already know the same
rule we can use that if we don't have a
right angle but there's actually a
version of Pythagoras theorem which
looks a lot like Pythagoras's theorem
but it's just like adjusted to work for
non radical triangles okay so underneath
here next to your non right angle
triangle I'd like you to write
Pythagoras's theorem again like so but
then if you have a different color there
I want you to put beside this or
actually not just beside next to this on
the same line I want you to write this
extra term
okay now this guy here is I like to call
it
it's a souped-up version of Pythagoras
theorem but you can see there's
Pythagoras right but Pythagoras's
theorem as it is doesn't work for non
right-angled triangles if you don't have
a right angle in there if you've got
some other guy like 30 45 81 whatever
angle you like to compensate for the
fact that it's not right angle you
subtract this thank you now why is it
this thing well if you want to answer
that question then you're asking the
question well how does the engine work
and I can't show it to you if you like
but for now I'm just going to put it to
one side we can still use this even
without knowing all the inner workings
okay now remember I said to you before
that an equation or a formula is usually
geared to find out whatever the subject
is right so the way I've written in this
is to find the hypotenuse okay this is
designed or it's written rather to help
you find this side over here so what do
you need to find that side you need the
other two sides a and B and then you
need this guy this is not just any angle
it's a particular angle which one is it
it's the Sun it's the angle that's
opposite can you please write that down
when you label this angle here it's a
specific angle right it's the angle
opposite the side you want I'm gonna
write that angle opposite this side you
want okay so for instance you could
actually know all of the angles in this
triangle you can know a and B and C but
if you want this side you need to pick
that angle okay this is the site this is
the cosine rule close up see it's got a
cosine in it okay so if you want you can
label this this is the cosine rule just
like the sine rule you can rewrite the
cosine rule if actually you don't want a
side if you want an angle you could read
it to find out the angle okay let's do
this see this I'm going to change the
subject
so that that
is the subject so I'm gonna have to
rearrange a fair bit okay so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
get on the left hand side I want the
subject on the left hand side okay I'm
gonna add this weed to a because the C
thing I'm gonna add it to both sides
okay so that leaves me with this on the
left I also don't want this C squared
here it's little C so I'm going to
subtract it from both sides so it looks
like that that makes sense I have added
this to both sides I have subtracted
this from both sides at this point I
only need to do one more thing which is
I don't want the two a B so what shall I
do
I will there's no movie I'm going to do
an operation of both sides which is
division so if I divide through by 2 a B
then on the right hand side I'll get
this okay so this is also the cosine
rule but it's keyed in a different way
to find not a side but an angle okay now
just like before
remember I said hey look see that angle
it's not just any angle it's the angle
opposite the side you want daddy's
equation here do you notice I can swap a
and B if if a was 8 and B was 10 I could
swap them around and wouldn't make a
difference do you notice that because
you do the same things to a and B but C
is different you see he gets subtracted
he doesn't get added so C is special
which side is it that makes it special
it's the side opposite the angle you
want right does that make sense
I'm viewing it from the other point of
view okay so please label that guy just
like in the original equation this side
is the special one this is the side
opposite the angle you want
okay
every question the middle one is how we
got from one to the other so it's like
just a bit of working really okay